In esports, a great play can stand on its own.
But it doesn't become truly iconic, it doesn't become ingrained in the hearts and minds of fans,
without great commentary attached to it.
I'm Colin for theScore esports, and previously we've given you the Top 10 Caster Calls, in Dota,
League of Legends, CS:GO, and fighting games.
And now, well it's time to give you the Top 10 Casters in Esports. Period.
These are the broadcast talents who give us goosebumps.
These are the guys who's commentary is attached to the most iconic plays from their esport.
These people are a big part of the reason we love esports.
(Casting)
Now before we get started guys, remember this is our list of the Top 10 Casters in Esports.
It's not an exact science. Yours might and probably will look a little different.
So sit back, get ready to post your own list in the comment section.
'Cause here are the Top 10 Casters in all of esports.
The first spot on our list goes to the best dressed caster in all of esports -- Auguste "Semmler" Massonnat.
You’ve most likely heard his voice gracing the broadcast of the Overwatch League
(Casting)
but between 2013 and 2017 Semmler became a legend casting Counter-Strike.
Alongside his duo partner Anders who, spoiler alert, we will talk about later in this list,
Semmler rose to the pinnacle of CS:GO casting more than 40 premier events and more than a few Major finals.
(Casting)
But whether it’s Overwatch or CS:GO, or any other game,
the level of professionalism and dedication he brings to the craft
mark him as one of the great ones when it comes to broadcast talent.
(Casting)
The number nine spot on our list belongs to Sam “Kobe” Hartman-Kenzler.
While the entire NA and, honestly, EU broadcast team is full of fantastic talent,
we couldn’t have this list just be 10 LCS casters.
Kobe has been involved with League of Legends from the very beginning,
joining Riot as a caster for the inaugural NA LCS season.
He's casted every split since as well as every mid season invitational and Worlds event in the LCS era.
(Casting)
If you’ve ever watched League,
you've very likely heard Kobe's voice over some of the games most iconic moments.
(Casting)
Kobe’s passion for the game shines through in his analysis,
As well as his hypest moments
(Casting)
Our number eight spot belongs to David "LD" Gorman.
The co-founder of Beyond the Summit brought the eastern Dota tournaments
like G-League and GEST 2012 to english audiences.
His work casting these S.E.A. events for the western world exploded his popularity
and he was invited to TI2 and the ball hasn’t stopped rolling since.
LD has casted every TI since 2012, more than 15 other premier events and,
through BTS, has supported many of the smaller community events throughout the Dota scene.
As far as his casting goes? His voice is attached to a moment known throughout the Dota community simply as
“The Play”
(Casting)
In the last five years LD’s voice has covered some incredible Dota moments,
and for that he’s certainly earned a spot on this list.
(Casting)
The faces of FACEIT League, James Bardolph and Daniel "ddk" Kapadia come in at the number seven spot on this
list.
This CS:GO casting duo came together in 2014 for FACEIT League Season 2 and quickly,
Daniel and James became fan favorites. It’s not hard to see, or hear, why.
(Casting)
More than simply casting the action in a round, Bardolph and DDK bring a level of wordplay,
hype and passion that has catapulted them to the top of the casting pecking order in Counter-Strike.
(Casting)
A great caster has the power to pull on our heart strings,
to remind us why we love the games we love,
and few do a better job of that than the number six entry our list,
Fighting Game caster James Chen.
(Casting)
Often heard alongside casting partner UltraDavid,
Chen has been a constant voice in the FGC for about a decade now.
With that experience comes a nearly unrivaled knowledge of fighting games.
And after all these years in the business,
after the unendingly long days casting pools or writing community guides,
after all the weekends spent locked up in hotel convention centres,
James Chen’s passion for the fighting games has only grown.
"Dammit, why'd he have to say that?
"You guys don't know, that's what got James the worst."
"It almost got me too."
"It wouldn't be EVO."
"Without that view, would it?"
"Tokido said it best."
"There's no other better way to say it."
"Fighting games are great."
"The fact that they bring all these people together to play for one hobby like this."
"At an event like this, thousands of people speaking the universal language of the fighting game."
As a pillar of the FGC, Chen’s emotion, knowledge and dedication epitomizes
what it means to be a great esports caster.
"This is what video games do. They unite us."
"They bring us together. They bring people from all sorts of different communities together."
"To enjoy something that we all love."
(Casting)
Peanut butter and jam, bacon and eggs... Sadokist and Henry G.
Rounding out the top five is a duo we just couldn’t bring ourselves to separate:
CS:GO broadcasters Matt “Sadokist” Trivett and Henry "HenryG" Greer.
While Sado provides lightning fast wordplay, humour, and play-by-play calls
that’ll have you on the edge of your seat,
(Speed Casting)
Henry brings the kind of gravitas to the action
that makes you feel like the entire world is resting on whatever play he’s casting.
(Casting)
Together, these two casters have produced more than their share of legendary soundbites
that remain unforgettable for CS:GO fans everywhere.
(Casting)
The number four spot on our list belongs to a duo affectionately known as the “Rain Bros.”
Christopher "MonteCristo" Mykles and Erik "Doa" Lonnquist.
Coming from Warcraft 3 and StarCraft 2 respectively both Monte and Doa
have a rich history in esports.
But the duo is perhaps best known for being the former English voices of Korean League of Legends.
"All aboard the Korean hype train."
(Casting)
From the latter half of 2012 to 2016 they were able to balance the jaw dropping action
with the slow and intellectual macro play the LCK region is known for.
(Casting)
In 2016 they made the jump to Overwatch casting Apex, the Overwatch World Cup,
and most recently the inaugural season of the Overwatch league.
(Casting)
No matter the game, we can always count on Monte and Doa to bring the hype,
and the laughs.
"Hey guys welcome to the LCK Summer on OGN. Your home for great teams, dank memes, and crushed NA
dreams."
(Casting)
Even if you don't know Dota, chances are you know the number three spot on our list.
Toby "TobiWan" Dawson.
(Casting)
He’s casted every international, and more than 30 premier events in Dota 2 alone,
with forays into Call of Duty, CS:GO, and even PUBG.
With his golden pipes
(Singing)
"It's a DISASTAH"
He's has become “the voice of Dota 2”.
(Casting)
With someone as entrenched and believed as Toby, there’s always more to say,
but in this case, we’ll let the legend himself do the talking.
(Casting)
In our runner up spot is the man who perhaps comes the closest to earning the title: “The Voice of Counter-Strike”
Anders Blume.
It’s hard to think about professional CS:GO and not hear his voice,
the voice that has graced so many of the game’s most iconic moments since the start in 2013.
(Casting)
Anders’ passion for CS:GO shines through in every game he’s ever provided the soundtrack for,
whether it’s casting with his longtime casting partner Semmler, or, more recently,
alongside fellow CS broadcasting talent Jason “Moses” O’Toole.
(Casting)
Five years on, his passion, his dedication and his ability to give us goosebumps hasn’t diminished one bit.
How do you take the most complex, the most nuanced and, sometimes,
slowest esport on the planet and make it something truly thrilling? Well you just call Tastosis.
"How do you know Protoss players are so famous."
"How?"
"'Cause they have a lot of Stalkers."
Taking our top spot is a casting duo that has been around since the dawn of esports time:
Dan "Artosis" Stemkoski and Nicolas "Tasteless" Plott
the Casting Archon.
(Casting)
Tastosis, as the duo are commonly known, were some of the first westerners on Korean soil broadcasting
the esports boom for the rest of the world.
"Hey what's up guys this is Tasteless. I'm down here in Seoul, Korea, as many of you may know."
"Filming me right now is Artosis."
"There he is right now."
Their chemistry, and the humour they infuse into every broadcast has made them the
most endearing casting duo in all of esports.
(Casting)
If you're not convinced yet,
these guys are so beloved, they made it into their own game.
(Casting)
These are… the casters’ casters.
I don’t care if you ever watched a minute of StarCraft in your life,
simply put: There is no other broadcast duo in the world that make you feel as electric,
and at the same time, as at ease, as Tastosis does. Even on the grandest stage of them all.
(Casting)
"When I get onto ladder I get my nerd gun out like this, point at em, gimme your god damn ladder points!"
Well guys that's our list and I gotta tell you, it was nearly impossible
to produce. We had to cut a lot of incredible casters and commentators, and it hurt my soul just a little bit
to do so.
What I want you to do though, is post your own Top 10 list of the best esports casters in the comments section.
And I will see you next week.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.